y à peu près un an je vous révéler une
maladie que j'ai une maladie laquelle je
suis atteinte c'est cette maladie est
connue sous le nom de tremblement
essentiel c'est un tremblement d'action
ça fait quasiment un an jour pour jour
en fait on était en vacances en famille
on était au soleil au ce prix des
vacances tranquilles épouse on se repose
[Musique]
nous voilà aujourd'hui en république
dominicaine on continue le trip vous
emmener depuis quelques jours avec moi
dans les bagages et en fait pendant
toutes les vacances j'ai nourri la façon
de dire est-ce que je parle de cette
maladie we know est ce que je dois le
faire parce que comme je vous
l'expliquais déjà dans cette vidéo il y
avait beaucoup de commentaires sous la
vidéo où on voyait tremblay et on disait
mes mecs arrête le café mec tu te prends
trop de coq tu manque de vitamine c on
s'inquiète qu'est ce qui se passe ça me
stresse tellement quand tu trembles
il faut que tous et de détente tu n'as
pas besoin d'être autant speed comme ça
tu trembles
est-ce que tu prends du coq hyper actif
en république dominicaine
la coque n'est pas loin mec j'ai juste
une question pourquoi tu trembles abuser
j'ai donc pris le temps de réfléchir en
disant est ce que je dois en parler ce
que je dois pas en parler est ce que
c'est le bon moment est ce que c'est un
sens réellement parle de teck ici donc
est-ce que ça a un sens que moi je vais
vous parler de ça parce que c'est un
truc extrêmement personnel et puis vous
savez j'ai vraiment retournera une
maladie on ne pas trop en parler c'est
toujours un petit peu délicat
et puis il faut savoir qu'aussi dans le
milieu professionnel milieu dans lequel
je suis il ya une personne qui raconte
par derrière qui racontait en tout cas
parce qu'elle ne fait a priori plus
aujourd'hui ça serait quand même est
venu qui a raconté que j'avais par
kingson
une fois j'étais à une soirée un
événement et à un accord que je connais
qui est mort qu'il fait et dit donc que
tout ton pote la balle une raconte pas
trop de choses sur lui moi je ne suis
pas plusieurs raconter les des choses
sur moi comme ça et du coup une diva
écoute nigra compte à la personne qui
s'occupe des relations presse que tu as
par kingson
merci et combien tu gagnes je ne parle
jamais d'argent je n'avais pas dit que
j'allais parkinson puisque je n'ai pas
parkinson et du coup je me dis [ __ ] on
se calme on se dit je vais pas faire
d'esclandre sert strictement rien mais
vous savez tout ça ça nourrit les
infections de se dire ok du coup à la
fin des vacances on se dit je pense
qu'il faut en parler je pense qu'il faut
le libérer la parole expliquez ça peut
aussi être assez vertueux nous voilà
donc partis de vacances avec une escale
de six heures 6 heures et demie je crois
à toronto
[Musique]
bon ben je profite hattestad quand même
relativement longue pour faire cette
vidéo mais devant les deux parties avec
ma petite caméra au poing dans
l'aéroport de toronto et choisir les
reins d'euros je pourrais vous parler en
novembre à là c'est pas forcément
évident qu'il ya du monde qui écoute
j'ai pas forcément très à l'aise parce
que par une fois de plus je parle de
choses extrêmement personnel et puis on
y va je tourne à gauche fait mes plans
dont la vidéo disponibles vous pouvez
aller la voir je la monte dans la foulée
et je le plot depuis ce que la
collection était quand même relativement
bonnes depuis l'aéroport toronto je le
pleure et ensuite j'ai un programme pour
qu'elle sorte à 7h heure française
heure à laquelle je sors tout mes vidéos
ou quasiment toutes à quelques
exceptions près donc ma vidéo sort je
suis dans l'avion je ne la vois pas il y
a quand même pas mal d'heures de vol
entre toronto et paris et pendant toutes
ces heures je me dis mais est-ce que
j'ai bien fait est ce qu'au final c'est
pas un jeu en train dé vois quelque
chose d'extrêmement personnel et quand
je vais arriver
comment est-ce que ça va être accueilli
qu'est ce que je vais lire et vous savez
on a toujours un peu la crainte alors
souvent quand je parle bien évidemment
de smartphones danois radio quelque
chose comme ça et bien jugé que les
commentaires sont peuvent être un peu
critique mais envers le produit là c'est
moi je m'expose je sais que ce que je
vous dis c'est moi je parle d'une
maladie qui m'est personnelle d'une
maladie que j'ai depuis de nombreuses
années je savais où quelque part qui
avait un pas un risque mais vous savez
on se fragilise dans une situation où on
s'expose et je les fais je voulais
envoyer je les publie en ligne et je me
suis dit bon bah advienne que pourra qu
on verra ce qui se passe j'espère que
soient pas trop mal accueillie mais bon
voilà c'est toujours un petit peu
délicat en tout cas de publier ça comme
ça et ne pas avoir une des sous les
commentaires pouvoir tout de suite quels
sont les premiers commentaires les
premiers retours voir un peu ce qu'il en
revient donc on arrive à paris je
descends je regarde ce qu'il en est je
regarde les premiers commentaires
arriver j'en garde le compteur d'eau
stade birkin à vue est ce que cette
vidéo semble en tout cas intéressés
l'audience pas bon de dire bye ajoute
qu'apple gens qui me regardent les
premières est ce qu'au final c'est un
sujet qui va aussi intéressé qui a paru
être un petit peu de libérer la parole
et là je vois qu'au final la vidéo
fonctionne plutôt pas mal et regardez là
je me sens leur dit alors là on est
effectivement un an après 1 an après la
vidéo a extrêmement bien marché on est à
3 117 1944 vue alors l'idée ce n'est pas
de faire une vidéo qui marche pour faire
des gros chiffres
mais pour dire qu'au final eh bien je
suis pas un porte parole je ne porte que
ma parole en tout cas les gens
s'intéressent à ce sujet et essaye de
voir un peu ce qui se passe ça apporte
beaucoup dans
ati et ça permet effectivement de faire
davantage connaître cette maladie et
c'était vraiment intéressant parce que
regarder 317 1944 vue vous donnant ça
quand même énorme pour une maladie alors
contenir une chaîne de teck 19000
poussent vers le haut
212 pouces vers le bas alors les pouces
vers le bas je sais pas toujours des
gens qui vont dire macoutes tu es malade
c'est pas bien j'en sais rien on sait
pas bref peu importe mais en tout cas
l'indicateur de 19000 poussent vers le
haut il n'y a jamais eu dix neuf mille
poussent vers le haut sur ma chaîne
ce que ça montre est est-ce que ça monte
toujours aujourd'hui c'est les gens
disent ok on apporte notre soutien
est-ce que j'ai beaucoup vu dans les
commentaires c'est bravo mec tu as été
courageux par oser le faire tu as pris
la parole et c'est extrêmement bien
accueilli et on peut regarder encore les
commentaires il ya eu 2019 commentaires
c'est peu c'est énorme
alors il ya eu de tout il ya beaucoup de
monde notamment beaucoup si de copains
sur youtube brandon avantage un vrai
testeurs stabilisation optique on
revient un peu ce dédramatiser le truc
et je trouve ça vraiment super il y en a
qui disent que j'ai effectivement il
n'avait pas remarqué tremblements ou pas
tu fais du contenu de qualité c'est pour
le plus important symbole il ya plein de
choses comme ça mon pote mister tahiti
mais aussi un joli message
on parle beaucoup de respect les gens
parlent aussi de leur propre expérience
j'ai 16 ans et ça fait un an que je
tremble effectivement il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui disent ok pour moi cette
maladie je ne la connaissais pas grâce à
toi j'ai pu me rencontrent cas de ce que
je pouvais potentiellement avoir essayé
de mettre des mots sur un symptôme c'est
à dire le fait d'avoir les mains qui
tremblent et dans tout ça et j'ai aussi
beaucoup de messages privés qui me sont
arrivées sur twitter sur facebook sur
linkedin sur instagram
il ya notamment un message qui m'a
beaucoup touché c'est un message qui m'a
été envoyé par léa et ça mais ça ce qui
m'a extrêmement touchée parce que vous
savez c'est là où on se rend compte
qu'en fait on n'est pas seul à travers
une commande et quand on est seul
toujours à travers sa propre maladie
c'est pas la maladie la plus grave
aujourd'hui j'ai pas au stade qui est le
plus énorme
mais malgré tout ça peut être
handicapant ce n'est pas le regard des
autres qui me dérange mais des fois vous
savez qu'on 11 films et que je me filmer
que seuls smartphones et que je me rends
compte que des fois j'ai les mains qui
tremblent un peu trop rigide
mince c'est pas non plus que j'ai envie
de montrer à travers la caméra c'est
comme ça c'est un fait voilà et du coup
le fait de recevoir des messages comme
ça et des messages de soutien des
messages vous parlent de ce qu'ils ont
deux ou leurs proches ça nous permet un
petit peu de jade une de relativiser
puis vous sentir un peu moins seul dans
tout ça et savoir que au final le fait
que j'ai parlé de ça le fait que j'ai
mis en public sur ma chaîne et que j'ai
pris la parole à ma petite échelle 1
sans aucune prétention eh bien je pense
que ça a pu aussi touché beaucoup de
personnes qui avaient ça et ça peut leur
faire du bien et c'est en ça que le
message de liam a beaucoup touché je
vais vous lire les quelques échanges
qu'on a eu et pour moi ça m'a vraiment
vraiment vraiment touché bonjour je
tiens à vous remercier pour votre vidéo
sur le tremblement essentiel
ma fille de 8 ans en est atteinte depuis
bébé et je vais lui montrer votre vidéo
pour lui montrer à quel point on peut
être heureux et épanoui avec cette
maladie si on l'acceptent
merci de votre courage je lui ai répondu
bonjour les gars merci de votre message
qui me touche énormément
vaincre le regard des autres peut être
parfois plus dur que vaincre la maladie
en elle même si votre fille arrive à
surmonter cela et se construire et se
construire avec elle sera beaucoup plus
forte que les autres
je vous envoie tout mon soutien et mon
amitié c'est ça moi ça m'a beaucoup
touché
vous savez c'est le fait de se dire ok
on sent que les a c'est dur pour elle
elle est maman elle a une petite fille
de 8 ans qui depuis est qui depuis
qu'elle est petite elle un tremblement
essentiel les maladies quand on les a 8
ans ça peut être encore plus
handicapante les enfants c'est compliqué
alors elle s'est construit avec ça fait
partie de son identité de vous savez les
enfants quel point ils peuvent être
cruels entre eux elle dira ok j'ai cette
maladie
j'en parle il fait dire regarde ce mec
je le prends en exemple mais j'ai pas
aimé revendique un exemple pour personne
mais fait dire regarde ce mec
regarde ce qui fait s'il le fait tu peux
le faire batwa et tu y arriveras et moi
je trouve ça fou et c'est vraiment ce
que j'ai voulu dire
et elle m'a répondu j'ai enfin montrer
votre vidéo à ma fille elle vous fait
passer un message et elle vous dit merci
d'avoir fait cette vidéo ça m'a appris
que ça n'allait pas m'empêcher de faire
des choses moi je lui ai répondu c'est
sûr mais au contraire ce qui nous tue
pas nous rend plus fort avec lui tu en
sais pas si lui ont remis dans le
contexte huit ans donc j'ai eu beaucoup
de messages comme ça il ya eu beaucoup
de manifestations d'amitié très très
positive
et voilà c'est ça nourrit pas vraiment
nourris et ça donne plus de force pour
affronter les commentaires à ce point
négatif de ce sens lors des commentaires
négatifs
il y en a encore je prends beaucoup de
recul la plupart du temps je me prends
ça d'où ça vient ça des jeux sur
internet il ya quand même un bashing
constant il ya une espèce de haine
déferlante et puis beaucoup de personnes
souvent les personnes qui s'expriment
comme ça représente vraiment une
minorité par rapport à la grande
majorité qui bienveillante et d'ailleurs
on le voit une foule plus en regardant
statistiques de cette vidéo le nom
de pouce vers le haut c'est vraiment
représentatifs ça montre vraiment ça ça
me permet donc moi de libérer la parole
et se content parce que il ya aussi une
personne qui est beaucoup plus connu que
moi braquo qui en aura beaucoup plus
large c'est clara look ciani pas si vous
connaissez
clara luciani moi j'aime bien ce qu'elle
fait super chanteuse
voilà bref on passe un peu le truc
qu'elle en a parlé dans les colonnes du
parisien alors qu'il avait 27 ans et
quand même c'est pareil jeunes mais
c'est souvent une indiquent qu'ils
arrivent plus autour des 50 ans donc
elle quand même relativement jeunes
aujourd'hui nous pouvons avoir
cette maladie mais alors pas elle libère
la parole et voyez ça fait partie des
choses qui sont importantes pour faire
davantage connaître cette maladie pour
que le regard change pour qu'on soit
plus à stigmatiser camions qui tremble
en hockey ces personnes qui tremble
c'est un alcoolique c'est quelqu'un qui
est en manque c'est un drogué c'est
quelqu'un qui n'a pas confiance en soi
qui prend trop de café et lé savoir quoi
encore les regards peuvent être vraiment
vraiment vraiment dur et vraiment c'est
à dire c'est pour ça que je suis content
que pour faire un dépôt de bilan il vous
en reparler un an après les choses ont
pu se passer
faisons plus tassé choses continuent à
évoluer pour moi sur youtube donc ça
c'est génial et je pense que c'est
important d'en parler alors aujourd'hui
j'en parle de cette manière là je
m'étais posé la question de dire est-ce
qu'il faut pas se rapprocher des
associations pour pousser les choses un
petit peu plus loin pour qu'ils aient
une journée dédiée au tremblement
essentiel en france pour faire un focus
encore plus fort cette maladie c'est pas
d'ma vie qui va te tuer mais c'est une
maladie qui handicape les gens et ce qui
est important c'est que les gens
prennent conscience que cette maladie
existe qu'elle est là qu on vit avec il
faut vivre avec qu'il faut pas juger
l'idée globale pour mme aujourd'hui
c'est ne pas juger quelqu'un petite robe
de ne pas juger un handicap quel qu'il
soit de ne pas juger les autres jeux
vraiment parler de respect de vivre
ensemble est bien évidemment de non
jugement j'avais pas prévu forcément de
vous en reparler un an après j'ai vu des
miniatures sortir j'ai vu passer guérin
donc vous avez publié ce jeudi
déjà un an que la face à une vitesse
incroyable
et voilà ça me paraissait pas mal au
final pouvoir reparler de ça pour
refaire un petit focus non pas pour
parler de moi mais pour dire ne jugez
pas les gens que vous voyez différent
les gens qui ont des comportements qui
vous semble un petit peu étrange
chacun a ses particularités chacun est
comme il est vivons ensemble serrons
nous les coudes et ça pourra se passer
beaucoup mieux sur ce je vous embrasse
peut demander vous dès demain et on va
parler avec bisous et à demain
oh
[Musique]